the numbers keep rising
argentina like the rest of latin america
is suffering a second wave of covet-19s
infections and deaths
the government has imposed a further
three weeks of new tougher lockdown
restrictions
a nighttime curfew and schools returning
to online classes
the authorities say their main aim is to
relieve the strain on hospitals
today the health system can't cope with
another patient not one more
we've reached our limit the number of
contaminated patients even if it doesn't
go up has reached breaking point
it's overflowing we can keep extending
measures every 15 days or two more years
but what we've got to do is test
and vaccinate
the arrival of vaccines has been slow
and sporadic
the argentinian government says it's
doing all it can to find new supplies
but so far only a small percentage of
people have had both jabs
the elderly and those with already
serious health conditions
in the meantime the only other option is
to keep asking its people
to be patient and cooperate
people need to be more aware and realize
that our hospitals are full
that the health workers are exhausted
and we all need to understand
what we as citizens need to do to fight
this
[Music]
but there have been demonstrations
against the government measures the
argentine economy
already facing severe difficulties
before the pandemic
has been hit hard
we're attracting a situation which we
understand is for our own good
but we've got no help from anyone to
help us fight through the pandemic
the constant request to pack up early
stay indoors
keep your distance have become for many
an annoying drone in the background
even though they understand that it
could be a matter of life or death
three million infections is a grim
statistic in a horror story
that also includes growing unemployment
homelessness and poverty
figures that will only keep rising until
the coronavirus is brought under control
daniel schweiner al jazeera buenos aires